PROFESSOR: Hi.
Today I'd like to introduce
a new module.
In previous modules we've talked
about how to model
particular systems, how to make
predictions about certain
kinds and classifications of
systems, and also how to
design both theoretical
and physical systems.
If our systems are operating in
a deterministic universe,
then we're all set.
We've accounted for all the
things we could possibly
account for.
But if we're making systems that
are going to operate in
the real world, then we need to
be able to deal with some
level of uncertainty.
Today I'm going to talk about
probability, which is the
method by which we're
going to model
uncertainty in our world.
And later we're going to talk
about different strategies we
can take to deal with that
uncertainty to hopefully
increase the level of autonomy
of our systems as they operate
in the real world.
The first thing I need to talk
about is how to properly model
probability, or how to
probably talk about
probability such that we can
use it to talk about
uncertainty.
When you're talking about
probability, typically you'll
end up talking about the sample
space or U. This refers
to your entire universe, where
your universe is the values
that you care about, or the
possible assigned values of
the variables that
you care about.
I'm already talking about
variables, but what I really
mean to say is events.
There are different states that
your universe can take,
and those states can be sort of
exhaustively enumerated or
be atomic, or they
can be factored
into different variables.
Let me elaborate on
this a little.
If I were talking about four
coin flips, if those events
were specified atomically then
I would have to exhaustively
specify all possible sequences
of four coin flips.
4 heads, 3 heads and 2 tail, 2
heads and 2 tails, that sort
of exercise.
Or flipping 4 heads would be
one event, flipping 3 heads
and then 1 tail would be a
separate event, flipping 2
heads 1 tail and another
head would be a
third, distinct event.
If we're talking about a
factored state space, then
we'll have a different variable
representing each one
of these coin flips.
And each one of those variables
will say, here is
the value associated with that
particular sub-event.
And the accumulation of all
those values, or the
specification for all those
values, will end up referring
to the same states that
were addressed
by the atomic events.
Let me talk about variables,
because they're the thing that
allow us to not exhaustively
enumerate every possible event
in the universe, and talk
about our universe in
meaningful ways, or in ways that
they can be effectively
communicated.
And why am I talking about
random variables?
Why aren't they just
variables?
Well, random variables is the
way that you specify the fact
that you're talking about
probabilistic variables.
When you're just dealing with
regular algebra, variables
have some sort of assigned
value, and you're not forced
to be in the space of 0 to 1.
When you're talking about from
0 to 1, when you're talking
about probabilities, you're
forced to be in the spaces of
0 to 1 and forced to remain
within the reals.
If you want to talk about all
the possible assigned values
of that random variable, then
you're talking about the
distribution over that
random variable.
This means that A could be
anything that A could be.
You're talking about the
function that says give me a
value of A, and I will tell you
a probability associated
with that value of A.
If you're talking about the
probability of A being
assigned to a particular value,
then you'll return out
the probability.
If A represents the color of the
shirt I'm wearing, and I
want to know the probability
that A is some value, then I
look at the color of the shirt
I'm wearing and try to
determine whether or
not it's 1 or 0.
Or possibly look at the colors
of shirts that I've worn over
the past year and make some sort
of ratio of the number of
pink shirts I've worn
over the past year.
If I'm dealing with a factored
state space, I'm going to end
up talking about more than
one random variable.
There are two main ways to
talk about more than one
random variable at
the same time.
One is joint probabilities,
where all the random variables
are collectively specified
at the same time.
And the other is conditional
probabilities, where you've
already decided that you
specified some value for one
or more random variables.
And then within that scope
you're going to talk about the
probabilities associated with
other random variables.
I want to demonstrate this
graphically, but there are two
more things that I need
to mention right now.
One is the difference between
frequentist and Bayesian
interpretations of
probability.
Right now they don't seem
particularly relevant, but
people will use these words,
and it's good to know,
approximately, what they're
talking about.
The frequentist interpretation
of probability is more
relevant when you're talking
about actions that happen a
lot of different times.
For instance, how frequently
it rains.
If I say that today is a
Wednesday, and I want to know
the probability that it rains
on Wednesdays, then that
probability is open to
frequentist interpretation
because there are a lot of
Wednesdays, and it's rained a
lot in the universe of
Wednesdays or the space of
possible Wednesdays.
So thinking about the fact that
there's a 70% chance of
rain, or a 30% chance of rain,
or whatever probability of
rain there is on Wednesdays,
makes sense, or is open to
frequentist interpretation.
The other interpretation that
you'll hear talked about with
respect to probabilities is the
Bayesian interpretation.
Bayesian interpretation tends
to be more relevant when
you're talking about spaces
that are more atomic as
opposed to factored, or
represent events that are
specified to the point that it
does not make sense to talk
about them in the frequentist
sense.
When we talk about probabilities
in the Bayesian
interpretation, we frequently
use the term likelihood.
For instance, if I'm talking
about whether or not it's
likely to rain on August 24,
2011 in the afternoon, the
specificity of that event is so
high that at that point it
doesn't make sense to talk
about the frequency of
Wednesday, August 24, 2011
in the afternoons,
at least for now.
At that point we're talking more
about likelihood and less
about frequency.
That event is more conducive
to Bayesian interpretation.
No whirlwind tour of probability
would be complete
without a mention of the three
axioms of probability.
The first axiom is that the
likelihood of the universe
happening is one, or all random
variables are going to
be specified at some point.
Relatedly, the likelihood of
nothing happening is 0.
What these two really do is
establish the boundaries of a
graphical representation
up here.
The other axiom of probability
is that if you're going to be
talking about the union of two
events, or the probability
associated with one or the
other event having an
assignment, then you're talking
about the probability
of one of those variables and
the probability of the other
variable, and then removing
the section that you've
double-counted.
So if I were to attempt to
demonstrate this on this
graph, I would be talking about
the probability of A,
added the probability of B.
And at this point I've
double-counted this section
the middle where
they're both one.
So I would subtract
this exactly once.
And then I'm talking about
the size of this space.
If I'm talking about the
probability of A being equal
to 1, then I'm talking about
the space in which A is
specified to be equal to 1,
divided by the area associated
with my universe.
When I'm talking about joint
distributions, I'm going to
find the space in which both
of these things are true,
scoped to the size of
the universe, or the
entire sample space.
So in this space both A and B
are true, and I'm looking at
it relative to the size
of the universe.
In contrast, when I'm talking
about conditional probability,
or the probability of A given B,
I'm going to look at where
my specifications are true,
scoped to where
my givens are true.
So if I'm already dealing in the
space restricted to B, I'm
just looking at this size,
or this space.
But because I'm scoped to B, I'm
going to end up dividing
by the area of B, instead
of the area of U.
This is the main difference
between the joint and
conditional distributions.
And a lot of people get hung
up on it, which is why I'm
exhaustively walking
through it.
A couple of other things before
we talk about the first
way in which we can use our
models for uncertainty to do
some amount of addressing of the
fact that we're going to
have to deal with uncertainty
in the future.
If we start off with a joint
distribution and we want to
reduce the number of variables
that we're actually talking
about, we can do so by
exhaustively walking through
all the possible assigned values
for the variable that
we want to disregard, and then
summing up the values
appropriately.
An easy example for this is if
we had the joint probabilities
of all the colors of shirts that
I wear and all the colors
of pants that I wear, and we
only wanted to talk about all
the colors of shirts that
I wear, then we could
exhaustively cover all the
different colors of pants that
I wear and accumulate all the
different values of shirts
that I wear simultaneously,
and then collect that
distribution.
Related is the concept of total
probability, which is
the same kind of accumulation.
It just operates in the
conditional space, as opposed
to in the joint space.
So in this case, if I'm already
operating in A given B
land, I have to scope myself
back out to the space of the
universe by then accounting for
the fact that I've only
been operating in the scope of
B. Then exhaustively enumerate
all the possible values of
B, sum the probabilities
associated with those values,
and then I've reduced the
number of dimensions that
I'm talking about.
The final thing we have to talk
about before we move on
to state estimation is
Bayes' evidence.
Or you've probably seen this
demonstrated as Bayes' rule.
If I want to talk about B scoped
to A, and all I have is
A scoped to B, B and A. When
we walked through total
probability, we saw that the
conditional probability
multiplied by the probability
associated with the variable
that we're conditioning on,
is equal to the joint
probability.
When we multiply P of A given
B by P of B, we're going to
end up with the joint
probability associated with
the two variables.
When we then divide back out
by A or scope our joint
probability to A, we end up
talking about conditional
probabilities again, which is
where B given A comes from.
Bayes' evidence, or Bayes'
rule, is the basis for
inference, which is going to be
really important for state
estimation, which we'll
cover next time.